[Music]
what are some of these differences
between men and women that you feel like
are not
socially constructed that are not
malleable that are not just based in
our current gender norms because
obviously there are some people on
on the quote unquote extreme or radical
left that would say
virtually all of our behavior and what
we consider to be typical male
aggression and typical female hoarding
by males
is is the consequence of the patriarchy
and not
our evolutionary history or our or our
genetics what do you say to that
um well you know whenever whenever we
start discussing you know the
evolutionary sciences
i think it's important to be aware of
some some
pitfalls in our thinking you know one is
called the naturalistic fallacy you know
and the idea that something
um just because we have an instinct for
it it's
necessarily moral or it's necessarily
desirable
or that it's inevitable right a kind of
deterministic way of thinking about it
a lot of times our instincts are none of
those things and the interesting thing
to me
is that is that people will commit these
errors in very stereotyped ways
depending on
what side of the political spectrum they
fall so on the left
on the left that mistake may be made
by thinking gender inequality is
undesirable so therefore
there must not be any biological
differences between
men and women or war is undesirable so
we
simply cannot have an instinct for it
right
and on the extreme right um
it may sound more like well
war is natural so therefore it's okay
you know there are gender differences so
that justifies gender
you know um inequality just to reiterate
the question
do you disagree with the sentiment that
our instincts even our instincts
like male instincts and female instincts
if you can call it that are
are socially conditioned and are the
product of our current environment or or
our historical development
rather than what's in our dna
oh i think i i think it's it's
it's it's rarely ever either or
you know i think i think we have a set
of instincts designed to
operate in a changing landscape and
adapt you know so i think it's it's both
i think i think if you were to say
you know um i think it's neither
so it's very infrequently
just learning or just or just instinct
it's both
you know but i think but i think to your
point i think the left
most commonly makes the mistake of
saying you know it can't be instinctual
you know it's it's got to be socially
[Music]
constructed
[Music]
you